the only way to hold a piece of ground
on this world
or any other world is a man with a rifle
hey guys
pete here this will be my breakdown of
for all mankind
season two episode three the episode's
titled
rules of engagement and this video will
include spoilers if you haven't watched
it yet
so we open with a news report about
panama four u.s
soldiers have been taken hostage and if
you're wondering what's going on
in panama they addressed the situation
there in one of those
shorts they put out to go along with
episode one
to fill in the blanks of what happened
this is one of those things i left out
of my timeline video
because i wasn't exactly sure what the
implications of it were gonna be
now we're starting to see that in the
news clip we see that the u.s president
ronald reagan is blaming the soviet
union
and part of the reason why panama is
important is related to the space
program
the sea dragon rockets which deliver
heavy payloads to the moon
are launched near guam and the pacific
ocean so they're dependent on the panama
canal
to get materials from the mainland out
to the middle of the pacific ocean
on the moon we see that the lithium
mining site that the us has established
has been taken over by the soviets the
lithium itself is a big deal it took a
lot of time and resources to locate it
there's a lot of it so it's worth a lot
of money and the idea of giving it up
isn't anything anyone's on board with
the president wants nasa to take it back
and to hold it will require them to
watch it 24
7. to do this ed and bradford realize
that they're going to need armed
security and armed security means guns
everyone else is opposed to the idea but
if you think about it bradford and ed
are probably right
it's not something that they can just do
though they have to modify
weapons and they don't really have
anyone up there who's trained to operate
them
this brings up the idea that they're
going to need marines because all of
their aviators have to train in ground
combat
first this idea doesn't go over well
with payne and the others although in
reality there were marines involved with
the u.s space program
john glenn was a marine bradford
delivers the quote that i opened the
video with
and that does seem to get through to
them and before we cut away
ed brings up the idea that once we do
this thing there's no going back
which sure feels like it has
implications about where this season is
going
later bradford asked ed in his office
about the time when the soviet cosmonaut
was in jamestown base
ed is reluctant to believe that
something might have happened while he
was there
but a little later in the episode they
sweep jamestown base
and they do find a recording device
above the light so it turns out for the
last nine years
the soviets have been able to listen
into what's going on in the base
this is one of the more interesting
developments here because ed is
devastated no doubt he feels responsible
and you could make an argument that he
is so i'm really curious to see how he
reacts to this
in relation to the space program itself
like his place in it
his guilt for what happened and how he
deals with that
one of the areas that i found less
interesting in the ed baldwin story
was his adopted daughter kelly making
her decision that she wants to go
to the naval academy this plays out over
several
scenes first she tells karen and karen
is completely against it she's not
supportive at all at first they get into
a fight
and we see where karen's fear is coming
from she went through that period of
time when ed was in korea
not knowing what was going on with him
she's lost her
son and i don't find it not interesting
because it doesn't work it all really
does work
by itself it just feels like it spreads
the story a little thin
either way later in the episode kelly
finds shane's popeye toy
in her room karen comes in she
apologizes
and eventually gives her her blessing to
go to the naval academy
and they both think that ed is going to
be really excited about this that she
wants to follow in his footsteps
when he comes home that doesn't happen
at all he actually flips out
and we've seen this side of him several
times throughout the series so it tracks
he tells her he won't support it kelly
tells him that she'll just go down and
enlist in the navy
he says that she'll have to leave the
house if she does that
he gets more and more unhinged and then
karen intervenes
and it gets pretty crazy and all the way
through this part of it i was right
there with them
it was intense you could feel the
emotion and the idea is there
that you know he's been suppressing this
idea that he wasn't there when shane
died that it was at least partly
his fault and things cool down and they
come back together and then it took kind
of a weird turn i thought
as karen tells him he's not responsible
for what happened
and then they all sing the navy's fight
song anchors away together i think there
were a couple things that didn't work
here for me but i think it can all be
summed up with
this part where kelly starts to sing and
karen goes oh please no
and it seemed like to me when i was
watching that wow the show's self-aware
they realize they don't really need to
go there
they don't really need to sing along but
then they just continued to sing
so to me it seemed a little dragged out
like i got the point early
what was going on here and then they
just kept going where
i didn't think it was as effective
anymore the interesting thing that
sticks out here though
beyond the obvious thing that they're
setting kelly up to be important later
in the story
is that ed has been blaming himself
because it happened while he was on the
moon
and that implies that that's probably
the reason he never went back to the
moon since then
so this could open the door for him to
go back especially
in light of the fact that jamestown's
had this recording device inside it
ever since he was there the last time so
the kelly stuff
i get it it's gonna be important later i
don't really love watching it
now but i'm sure it's going to pay off
and we see that
in the margot and elita timeline because
the elita parts
in season 1 seemed a little bit out of
place and i have to admit that this
reintroduction really did work for me in
this episode i'm really curious to see
what's going on with lolita
just to recap we see margot arrive at a
trailer park
we learn that elita lives there there's
the awkward introduction where she has
to help her with the toilet paper
because she's out of it and she's in the
bathroom
and we learned that elite is going to be
deported if she doesn't have a job
that she's a gifted engineer but she
keeps getting fired
she's basically worked everywhere boeing
abbott mcdonnell douglas
and when margot looked into it all those
guys that fired her
still said that she was a gifted
engineer one of the best that they've
ever worked with
between these two though we can see that
there's a real tension
and feelings about their past the
takeaway from the ending of season
1 was that margot turned her away
thinking that she would be all right
staying with the woman she was already
with when elita went back there the
place was cleared out and before she
took off on her own
she lied to her father on the phone
saying margot agreed to let her stay
is that what they're talking about have
these two not seen each other since that
day nine years ago
and how did elita get from that place to
working at all these big aerospace
companies
what she was doing in that period of
time brings up a lot of questions
in the end there is a job offer it seems
like margot has regrets about the past
but she's trying to offer a practical
solution
for the real problem of deportation that
elite is facing
it's definitely interesting i like the
grown-up version of the character so far
later after margot leaves we see elita
fight with her boyfriend
over the fact that he brought margot
into their lives she says it's the one
person she didn't want help from but in
the end she agrees that she'll take the
job
only to break up with the boyfriend for
going behind her back
it appears that she will be working at
jsc it doesn't sound like she's starting
off in anything
important but it will obviously lead to
something paying off all the
introduction time that we spent with her
in the first
season and that just leaves us with
gordo and tracy we see that tracy is
sleeping in waking up taking a swig of
beer
having her housekeeper call in to say
she's gonna be late
we learned that gordo called her and
left a message
at his house we see that he doesn't fit
in his uniform anymore and there's a
pretty funny scene where he breaks the
zipper
he does make it to his class danny jokes
about him about not being in uniform
and we see that they have laptops in the
class which seems to be another example
of the development of technology being
sped up a little bit in this timeline
later we see tracy coming to the outpost
and it's very
noticeable that she's drinking heavily
here at first karen's distracted with
the kelly news
tracy does give her some good advice
there and then all that drinking leads
to her wrecking her porsche on the way
home
after she sees a billboard of herself
because her husband's out of town she
calls gordo to come pick her up
she pukes in his car and insists that he
take her back to their old house
his house and as he's getting the couch
together she takes off her clothes and
goes into the bed and takes it from it
the next morning he takes the keys to
the house back before tracy leaves and
they argue about it
she pretty coldly laughs in his face
when he says he's going back to the moon
and he explains that he's on jamestown
91 that colombia will be taking him back
in september
and she realizes she's going to the moon
on discovery and that they're going to
be there at the same time
he's hurt because he's going back to the
moon for the first time in 10 years
and the only thing she seems worried
about is the publicity and we see more
of that when she goes to ed's office and
tries to get gordo bumped from his
flight
they also argue and in the end he's
still going
tracy believes that gordo came to him
and asked but as viewers we know ed
is doing this because he's trying to
pull gordo out of that dark place that
he's in
and it's a little bit hard to square for
me why this is such a big deal
they mentioned shorty powers who's a
real person in our timeline
that worked for nasa and her problem is
that she's worried that they're going to
try to force this into a situation they
can use for publicity
she says she won't play the astro wife
again so it's there
i don't know it's not the most exciting
thing for me but if you think about the
scenes that she's been in so
far this season she does seem to be on
the edge of
something going wrong in her life and
probably the thing i was most curious
about
for either character was the closing
shot where we see gordo in his bed
and the tv cuts out he goes and turns it
off he lays down
and then he sees red lights in the
distance and of course this brings us
back to whenever things started going
wrong for him on the moon
it turns out it's just his vcr and he
has a laugh about it but it underlines
the idea that there is some concern with
him going back to the moon
and so the episode ends there and i
think overall it was still pretty good
even though there were some parts i
didn't like as much as others
my take on the anchors away seeing the
sing-along not being necessary
may turn out to be an unpopular opinion
but it did remind me of parts in the
first season
where i thought that the number of
things that they're trying to do all at
the same time
sort of took away from the overall
experience
the whole idea of the situation with the
soviets how things on earth are
impacting how they decide to do things
on the moon
there's a cool dynamic there where
there's just a few people on the moon
overall but what happens between them
has really big
implications and they're separated from
us in that way they're out in space you
know
ed finding out about the listening
device makes me wonder about where his
story's headed in this season
in the previous episode there was this
idea of putting together a publicity
stunt
a handshake in space between the us and
the ussr
it was kind of pushed aside at the time
because there was other things going on
and because payne said that it was never
going to happen either way
all of this is starting to point to me
thinking that this is gonna happen
and there's gonna be far-reaching
implications and of course the idea of
taking guns to the moon
is obviously going somewhere and i think
that's a good place to leave it so let
me know in the comments what you thought
about this episode what you think about
this season so far
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already
and thanks for watching guys i'll talk
to you soon